you're never like in the midst of like
you because you have to work in such
tight quarters like you're always just
together when you like in the moment
there's a lot of like couples on TV that
have renovate renovation shows and stuff
like that and I feel like you one of a
couple right just so you know no I know
but I feel like I could feel the tension
I never feel like actual tension there
well we had one shouting match like a
month ago about something well something
else was bugging you so Jonathan was
already in a bit of a huff and so um and
then I could just see the tension and
basically long and short of it was we
were we're we were permitted to shoot on
the on the street where we were and
there was a woman opened her window had
her window open and she yells out at us
excuse me can you move down the street
I'm you're you're bothering me and we're
like oh so sorry we're literally one
more minute we had one more minute left
we've been filming for 20 minutes yeah
we've been there for 20 minutes and
she's like stop now what were you
bothering like what is what do you hear
she just said the noise of our
conversation we were just talking crew
crew was literally filming our
conversation so it would' be like you
know well this this house is such and
such and this house and such and and uh
so she's like stop talking now and so no
joke very kind I'm like oh my gosh I'm
so sorry we're one minute and we're done
we'll be out of your hair and she's like
no now you stop now and I like this is
the problem I have no time for
and if people are being unreasonable I
my tolerance level is very low I will
come in here and say jonan says in a
very kind voice I said from my
perspective it was a very passive
aggressive voice that said uh oh it
looks like we're going to be done in
just a minute so maybe you're bothering
us okay and then and I'm like no that
was the second round right right so
anyway long story short he blew up more
than I thought he should I'll tell you
I'll tell you what I said cuz it's funny
this woman like she keeps going on and
she's like shut your window she's like
I'm dealing with I'm a psychiatrist and
I'm dealing with clients and you're
ruining everything and so I said you
know what might actually help if you
just close your window then maybe you'll
stop bothering us and then she goes like
what did you say she's like no and then
I I said to her one more time I'm like
yeah I don't know this is I'm thinking
you might need some of your own medicine
and uh anyway that's when Drew's like
stop sh and I was like I just have no
time for people's BS so that was the
last argument we got in because he drew
did not want me saying that I was like
well after I I walked up to him very
calmly just to say what is going on and
he's like don't even I know exactly what
you're going to say and I'm tired of
people's and whatever I'm like
okay someone needs to have what we're
saying is time out watch out guys don't
give me any well anyway we had
uh you know I I what we did find out
it's funny you should tell that story
that woman had just received a phone
call from her Doctor Who informed her
she only had 11 minutes to live so and
the last two minutes so every minute
every minute counted so we got those
quality
minutes
I